okay
for people joining this live stream we
are looking at some
features for version 12.2 of of language
features related to cryptography and
in particular we're looking at pem files
and the question is so
a pen file is supposed to be a
permissions file
that is going to be used for a variety
of purposes right
there yeah it's more than that yeah it's
a file can contain a lot of
cryptographic data but it can also
contain arbitrary data but it is largely
used for
storing an exchange of keys and security
certificates
in the all private key infrastructure
parts of things okay so
how does it relate to um
our existing secured authentication key
how does it relate to this
well daria it it doesn't it relates to
security certificate
it relates to private keys public keys i
know but this has that
as well right this has private and
public keys as well
it happens to be mostly oauth related
but but
it was intended that this would be a
more general construct
is ever stored in the file
and we are talking about importing
existing files
okay do i need let's let's open this pem
format towards format pages
lower it's about 10 down yeah
okay so we got a bunch of weird
background noise by the way here
i'll go lead
i still got background noise so it's not
you
okay
okay so i don't understand this is
importing from a pen file and just
returning a public key
i'm very confused this is a pam file
that contains
a public key but how structured are pem
files
they have a well-defined standardized
structure
so for the rsa this would be first thing
type goes to rsa public modulus because
this
sort of thing okay but is it is it uh
why are we returning this
in a i'm very confused here if
if we have something a pm pm file is one
or more
uh has one or more sections that are in
on the left you can see it like it has a
begin and an
end section and then there can be
different things so that you know can
start with a private key
and then it can have a public key it can
have a security certificate or tens
security certificates it can have things
that we don't support yet
in which case they're sort of like you
know okay but do they does each kind of
thing that it has
have a have a title yeah do you
understand what i'm saying
so we should probably have it return an
association where the keys
are the titles of those different
sections so you can access them
yeah we there is another import element
for that
so like there would be an import element
called raw data that is going to return
that association without any
wolframising
but because we could use it as public
key
the default we decided well can we i
mean but if we don't even know the
format and it's coming in on a list it's
not going to work it's just a
you know i'm sure if we feed this to um
encrypt
it's not going to work because of that
list for example no it is good
yeah so it returns a list of the
elements right so the output here could
have been
you know the first element could be a
public key the second element could have
been a security certificate
like look at the second example right
that's a list of two things
because that has the client.pm file has
two
two of those sections in there and then
it's up to the user to decide okay i
need the private key or i need this
security certificate yeah but but but my
question is this are they
are they picking it by saying cases of
this
underscore security certificate or are
they picking it because it is a
because there is one security
certificate there and that is a named
element of the pem file
or can a pen file contain 17 uh you know
security certificates
it can yeah it can yeah so it's just a
bag of stuff
where each individual piece is defined
yes right so we return it as a list i
think if i understand you correctly
we could return it as an association
with the maybe some sort of
well if if it has titled it with
something
if it if it has um
if it's some if if there are titles
within the pem file
but they're not unique well if
if a file contains 10 searches
certificates
it would make no sense to put them in a
session but it makes sense to put them
on the list
okay all right i get it okay so
walk me through okay so
all right well so let's look at the next
next piece of this okay so by the way
have you edited the guide page at this
point
not yet because we wanted to settle down
names first
okay um i think you're not looking at
the source guide page here either so you
no i'm not
i'm not i'm not telling you so let me
look at security certificate as well
this sounds like a sensible thing for us
to have but
but now in it see also where does it
have
shouldn't it be pointing at the keychain
stuff as well
it could yeah make a note of that yeah
well i'll just change it um and by the
way it doesn't don't isn't there a new
way to specify
uh formats in here how do you do that in
the c also
there's a new way does it automatically
okay
all right okay um okay
what is the uh uh what is it called sick
what what do you
uh what is the business you mean or oh
system credential yeah
i think right that's the system credit
yeah there's a there's a
couple of those functions but system
credential is the main one i think
yeah okay because that seems relevant to
security certificate
okay issued for a public key
so do these agree
with the things that we're using inside
the main cryptography
what do you mean well i mean so if i
take public key from a security
certificate
okay so can i read okay next question
when i'm reading certificates from a
website from https for example
how do i import can i get the security
certificate for our
you know for orphan.com or something
from how do i get that
from url read or whatever else is there
a way to get that
there is not way to get yet from url
read
but you can import it from the browser
save it on the file and import
that that is planned though that's
something where you need to see there is
a futurized cell
there that says from url execute that's
just not
oh i see yeah okay
in a browser you can manually download
the certificate and then you can
you know run it through the basis to get
it involved in language
so in other words what it will look like
in the end is url certificate url
execute or url read of a website comma
security certificate and then the return
value
will be this symbolic security
certificate is that correct yeah
yeah i don't know what the shortest path
is at the moment to go from
there okay when you say digital
signature here
it's returning a digital signature
object is that correct
yes and you can actually verify it with
verified digital signature
that's cool and also
put it in your cryptography course darya
this is this is going to be a good
section in your cryptography course i am
going to do that yes
there is an example on this page in the
scope that says the whole process of
verifying
oh yeah this one
cool okay all right okay all right i'm
i'm sold on the security certificate
thing
okay and this in the documentation that
table is in the order that
those you know the certificates come in
so that the table is in a very specific
order that
it needs to be in like it comes like
that
it's intentionally not alphabetic or in
a different order just that
i understand that's the right thing to
do here
okay but now how do i get out the full
association
it's parameters yeah parameters
just below the people all right okay i
mean maybe all could do that as well
or normal of security certificate
like normal of security certificate
right now just normalizes the
association inside
and so normal was not
okay well i don't think that's a not
obvious that's a good idea anyway
um all right normal too much
okay let's look at the crypto this is a
weird thing
well this is not related to pam like i
know it isn't but
it's a weird thing anyway why do we have
a
why do we need this well we want to be
able to
sorry yeah so like for the version 12
we have supported only one curve so far
which is the ccp256
but now we we can support more and we
will need more
for for example for blockchain
implementations
and it's nice to provide the user with a
list of possibilities of the curves that
all right i mean there are like a
hundred of them stephen
and we don't support all of them you
know we previously we only supported one
now we support six or seven right we're
going to add more
the important ones right okay also
in signatures and certificates there is
a parameter you actually specify which
curve is used
and so it can it may specify a different
curve
okay listen i think these names should
be turned into our versions of these
names
but capital ps and so on yes we talked
about it but
these are standard and uh that's how
people recognize them
well many things i mean i
it's hard to sort of like turn it into
uh if you change the name
it will be hard to match it with the
standard one because
but what about capitalization does
anybody care about capitalization
i mean we could do capitalization
because we could just do two lowercase
and that's fine but then
prime this first two curves we're going
to have only p capital
then the last curves are going to have
all the cec
capital because that's an abbreviation
also if you capitalize uh there is no
there is no uh
order in how the names are spelled in in
various places so some of them are
capitalized some are not
it is hard to match the one that is here
because there is no
actual actual uh description of the
curve except the name
that would characterize it exactly
okay if i look up this curve on the web
yep am i going to find it lower case
everywhere let me find out
yeah well except
you know i love the way you say that i
just love the way you say that
which capitalizes yes just to be clear
this is the output that you get from
open ssl you know dash option
names i think so it's kind of a yeah
there it is these are all you're looking
at is the actual standard that has
introduced this curve so they are so the
owners
of the name well so how do they name it
loyalties
it would be an exception to to all of
our naming conventions
some names are even weirder they contain
underscores
and yeah
there must be other places where we just
have kept the original you know
i don't know what you know what i i
would go for it if we called this
cryptographic elliptic curve names
okay it is a list of names yeah
okay so let's let's
um you could have some functions you
could have also parameters
and that's different symbol at some
point i'm sorry say that again
what if we call this names it's fine
because then we can have another symbol
that's going to have parameters if we
want to introduce them you know
yes by the way i see on our live stream
is asking about
curve 25519
we are actually going to have it soon
because
we are starting a partnership with a
blockchain that works on it
so we're going to edit but probably
after 12 2 we're going to have a pocket
update with that curve
wow okay it's like fine wines or
something
maybe we need a function that would come
that would basically
convert names into parameters and maybe
dig it down that sounds
overly i think this is fine okay
okay and and we did talk with the uh
you know special functions people
initially we just thought about calling
it elliptic curve
names or but clearly you want to make it
they don't want that
yeah they don't want that because that's
a that's a whole different thing
yeah so we made it specific to be you
know dollar cryptographic
i think that's the right thing go ahead
what
a lot of people you know this is a bit
of a technical detail but it's useful
for
you know people that really know right
even the fact that we have even one
person on our live stream who's asking
after a particular curve
that's a good sign um yeah probably
we saw this name but we don't support it
currently
well darius says it's coming so um okay
let's um uh
let's go back to the pem object thing
okay
all right what on earth is this creature
this is um sort of
a zoo of everything that a pm file can
have that is not a private key
public key or a security certificate
that we don't have ahead why don't we
just return it as an association
because there are files that can have uh
if you scroll down on the cryptography
review notebook there is an example of a
file
in the design notes of the agenda that
has
a key a certificate and a pm object in
the same file
and like this was the initial
decision to have a separate head for
this because
then this last output what what is a pm
object define a pem object
it is some object like private key or
certificate or anything
else that we don't have a head for
we don't but we cannot compute so we
just returned as an object
we can parse it uh we can extract
things but we don't promise anything
to be computable but i i understand that
i understand that by the way somebody is
asking what's the timeline for release
of this library
well all the cryptography stuff in
modern language has been there for
lots of it has been there progressively
when did we start adding this stuff like
five years ago
i think version 10 okay
there that's looking crypt probably says
2015. i was right five years ago
um but the stuff we're discussing right
now is going into version 12 2 which is
uh it's code officially froze yesterday
so we are doing bad things by changing
anything here
um okay so i'm still trying to
understand where would you use a pem
object i mean i understand that you want
a container
for random gunk that came in from an
import
but i mean we have just to give you an
analogy when we import exif data from an
image
we don't have an exif object head
we talked about it with uh sean sheeran
from the import group
and i think this we arrived on this
because it was an analogy to the xml
object it's just sort of a general
you know holder thing for for things
that don't
you know that we don't have anything
else for
yet so it is basically
if you know what your file consists of
and you know what to do with pm object
then you can
work with it but who can who consumes a
pem object
right now no one okay so what good is
this doing
does it you can extract fields from
people
may have you know 20 security
certificates right 20
private keys and one thing that we don't
really have a good way of representing
and so then that's just you know the pm
object
it's the general case that you know i
mean this file format is just very
interesting so
hold on hold on the file has a title for
each section
and contents for each section is that
correct yep
okay and the contents we can pass so we
can
go okay can we parse a hundred percent
of the contents
in other words there's a limited there's
a limited grammar of possible contents
for the sections of the file
is that true no no
it can it could contain anything
what do you mean it can take anything it
can contain a picture of a of a
you know of a a smiling lizard or
something
yeah you cannot call it into pm object
yes into pm file
and the thing is yeah if you're looking
at the private key file
in the pm object it's going to be a
title begin private key
and then there is going to be a list of
integers and because the structure is
standardized we are now that the first
integer is a modulus
then the second initial is the exponent
then the third integer
is the factor okay all right fine but
what's going on the standard but for a
random pm father it's going to say begin
something okay what do we return the
thing as are we returning this as a byte
array or we're joining it as text
is
saying that there are things which are
not okay in the case of
is this a key when it says ec private
key is that
it says begin title could i say begin
lizard here instead
yes yeah okay fine but this thing here
begin ec
private key is that something special
yes okay how many of those special
things are there
around 20. okay
how many of those 20 things can we parse
a lot like um wicked parse
uh ec private key rsa private key just
private key okay okay fine
and we parse them into things like
security certificate
right is that correct yeah yeah
yeah okay now what you're concerned
about is
things that have a title
but are unparsable by us is that correct
yes but also things like uh that are
partial to some extent but we don't have
a head for
like do you ever like what we can plug
objects documentation there is content
types include
okay so here's what i suggest we do we
do not want to have at this pem object
thing it's
it's just too weird it's what i think we
should do is something where if you say
it's going to be this random list
of things that we can parse things we
can't parse
what you're talking about is an import
of a pem file right
by the way if i if i just go to the web
and i find a random pem file
well let me correct a little bit uh we
can't parse it
but we get a tree of bunch of integers
and strings we cannot interpret it into
a
meaningful structure
i understand um how do i do a search
let's see is it called file type how do
i do a search for um
search for pm example file maybe
no i'm saying isn't there isn't there a
type arrow pem or something i can search
for
type column yeah that's what i thought
um well like i can put something on this
on his own chat if you
if he's looking for something like
you're just looking for a random thing
right i'm looking for a random pm file
that i can just import
if you look at the zoom chatters mean
this is literally the first one i found
so i don't know what it is
but no i want something which is which
is called pem
where i can say import of the thing with
the pem
well you can just do import string on
that right i mean on the on the thing
just copy and paste the thing and use
import string on that yeah and press
string works
okay all right so i have this pile of
random gunk here
okay and i can say import string
of this pile of random gunk right
comma pem yeah
[Music]
um
it has three dots in the middle it's not
a full file
ellipses in the middle of the file sorry
that's my bad
okay let me keep looking your message
should be better
oh yeah that's
i don't know what import usually does
but but um
well we have agreed on this messages
with emperor grip
the thing is that some of these uh uh
objects may fail but some may not
okay so so another issue is these
comments in the
pen file those are comments on the pen
file presumably anything
anything except the blocks i ignored all
the lines
so they can take comments about the
certificate or anything
um yeah
okay but so so this format dash dash
begin blah blah blah
look what i suggest
doing is that what comes in is you've
got a list
you know security certificate blah blah
blah
digital signature whatever whatever
things there are
and it's a pity that you lose the
comments but whatever
and then when you have an unknown one
what you do is you say
title blah blah blah blah blah content
blah blah blah blah blah
and if we can do better than that great
but we're going to be very for those
right i mean that that can be pages and
pages so it's going to
be uneven with the other ones so the
structure here
is different you cannot map a function
over it because
security certificate perhaps a an
association
so it's a two level thing i know the
third element is a session directly
so look this is a bad idea okay
you know how many formats do we have 500
how many
formats have their own special wrapper
to you know like hdf for example you can
put all kinds of random junk into hdf
okay we do not have an hdf object
wrapper
that says put your random junk in here
see if we can't do anything with it i
mean arguably
the default import for a pen file for us
should only import the things that we
can understand
and there can be an element that gets
you other stuff as well
but i just don't see this i i don't
think it's a good idea
okay his alternative approach is to have
a generic
head which is common for all imports
like imported object
so that's fine yes but but i mean we've
never done that it's
not a bad idea um
i mean that is a perfectly reasonable
idea but
can we get somebody from the import
export team here
and let's talk about that i i don't
think that's a bad idea
i just don't want to see sean for
yep i'll try to get someone
so basically what goes inside we cannot
we don't make any promises
but uh here you go yeah
well i think what we would do with
imported objects is we would say it's
pem
you know what we would say is um you
know
uh something like original format right
i mean we could we could just say
imported object yes that's a reasonable
thing
original format pem you know
raw data blah blah blah whatever it is
and it might have to be a byte array
that is good because raw data is a
property for
all the other things so
like many formats have raw data like
ml formats hdf well so what
the point of this thing would be
um the point of it
would be to have something where i mean
if if the whole of what's being imported
is
is unknown to us this doesn't do us much
good you might as well say import
you know the thing as a string right the
case where this is relevant is a format
which is a multi-part format
where some parts are understandable by
us and some are not
right and that is a good general case
and i'm surprised we have not introduced
this before
um i don't have a problem with this and
then then we could have a
a uh summary box for this and so on
okay good that's good um
that's fine by me there is a system
function called raw data but i don't
think that's
no that's something completely different
that was a very early version one thing
which has not been
you know which is now something no never
been documented
um
okay all right so then what we what
we're doing here
all right i'm happy with this i think
it's actually a good idea and i think
they're probably a bunch of other places
like i think in some mail formatting
stuff that's something we could
potentially use
you know for for cleanliness and
elegance
no i think it's a good idea but so let's
do it more generally
um all right
what else do we have to figure out here
we have to i mean we might as well edit
the guide page while we're at it
um and uh
and then i will be happy to depart here
okay did you already have proposed edits
on here
where does this go wait a minute so
first of all there's
boy aren't there other uh file formats
what what would you so there is a
commentator
thing uh it's besides spam
there are there are a few other
extensions that are actually
same format yeah because spam can be
files dot key dot crt dot cr
and we can import those too because
the thing is that they have the pen
encoded they don't have db.pan
specifically but we don't
export yet right now yet we need to fix
that
import keys from not input and export
okay well also this import string which
can be useful to people
oh that seems to be probably formatted
wrong okay so now this is key management
but now where does where should
um certificates go where does security
certificates go
do they go under digital signatures
management as well
because a security certificate says that
you are the owner of this public key
okay so i should put this under here
security certificate here yeah that's
correct
so what is this this is representation
that's not very exciting just say
representation of a security certificate
can i can i define that
what's that
public key security certificate
i mean it's really okay
all right that was easy enough okay now
um on this page
we're pointing to system credential i
assume you pointed back
from public key back to security
certificate yes
i hope so i don't remember
okay where should it go in that list
what should i generate digital signature
before encrypt decrypt i guess
definitely not before encrypt and
decrypt definitely not
i mean
should we put system credential on this
page is that relevant for storing
i think it's relevant for storing these
keys isn't it
it is relevant
maybe we should put it before oil of phi
okay and that means also in private key
we should also put system credential for
sure
private key we should put the pem thing
and
system financial right
okay um is it relevant for
none of these things are relevant for
encrypt and decrypt they're always
but what about digital signature isn't
it relevant to that verify digital
signatures and that doesn't shouldn't
that point to security certificate
yeah they could tell me where
beforehand
i i let you guys figure out if there are
other cross-references here
um yeah we'll go like before we release
i will go through all this older pages
you know and update the examples
look okay cryptographic elliptic curves
um does that want to go boy that's a
that has to go to generate a symmetric
maybe keeper
um well it also goes under cryptographic
number theory i would assume
oh yeah that's relevant yes
wow thank you generation
okay
something like that
yeah okay
and does that need to cross link well
you you'll put in those crosslinks
um yeah i already put in like generate a
symmetric key pair that like you can
obtain the list of supported curves by
okay um all right anything else we need
to do in this
and this meeting sean is here i don't
know if we want to continue with that
part of the conversation yes let's just
check that
okay pem files
are long sequences of random blocks of
stuff
some of those blocks of stuff we don't
understand
shawnee you hear just uh i'm not talking
to nobody
yeah um the concept is to introduce a
new symbolic head called imported object
that contains that is for
sub-pieces of imports that we don't
understand
do you understand what i mean sort of i
thought that we'd already addressed that
by
introducing a generic like pm object
thing we're not going to do that
we're not doing it that's actually a
replacement for that
we're not doing it we don't want to have
this for every for you know
600 formats or whatever where where each
500 of whatever we're at
right now where every single one has a
you know you know what i'm saying
right you just want to general right in
general
because because many of these formats
here i'm quite certain
that you know some like dicom i bet
those things in dicom
that are just weird random things that
come from a particular mri machine
that we can't import right but which we
could
store as an imported object does that
make sense
okay a lot of the metadata is things
like you know dates strings and other
stuff i mean
maybe could have some kind of no but the
whole point sean is this
there are things where it is a different
branch it is metadata
okay that we can deal with that the
issue with pem that is new and different
is there's a sequence of
similar things where it's like okay this
one is good this one is good this one is
good oh whoops this one is one we can't
import
but um okay so if we can't import it why
isn't it something like missing
because we can import it we can import
it as raw stuff
okay so this is just some generic head
for that kind of thing
what this also sounds like to me is the
xml stuff
it does xml object xml element which
is needs to be modernized yeah that
that's very true
i mean those expressions themselves just
grow to be so huge
so quickly with large data i know i know
i know i know i know i mean
once we have the trees project done that
will
flow into the xml thing well okay
um remember this different right xml by
its very definition is some sort of
you know very general format that we
import you know as a wall from language
expression using xml object
you would you don't want to change that
to imported objects or something
right it's just well i don't think so
in the case of xml i think that there's
more natural things like associations
that could
represent that stuff and we need
more efficient data structures is the
important thing with xml it's got to be
efficient
i know but we have right we do have 30
years of you know
people with code that import xml so you
know you want to be careful about
changing all that
right and i'm not saying necessarily to
get rid of it you know completely but
i'm saying to introduce new elements
with more modern stuff that could
actually be efficient
yeah okay yeah we've got lots of stuff
to do with xml which we can do with
trees
sound on our live stream is pointing out
the pam file is a bit like importing a
folder or a zip file
yes where we but in those cases we have
file names and so we can import an
association
that has distinct file names with each
piece of of
of uh result in it well and there's all
kinds of other metadata
in you know various zip and tar formats
um zip has a
table of contents at the beginning of it
and whatnot the tar format has
some information before each chunk of
data okay
um so i mean they're different
i could see how you would think they're
fairly similar but
so let's go back to this other thing the
what is it called
imported object
okay so what's inside of it an
association
that has a few standardized keys and a
bunch of
random keys
and right now we would use this only for
pam
but i think we'd end up using it for a
bunch of other formats too i i vaguely
remember the things in mail
where we needed this and we didn't have
it
so the thing is we can uh read read the
data
and we can parse it but we don't know
what it is
no but no no but but constantine this is
a very specific case
we have there are sequence of blobs of
data
some of which we can read and some of
which we cannot read
that's the point that's the case that's
unusual usually it's either we can read
it all or we can't read anything
um
okay there's a question here on
livestream can you create your own
positive rules as a user absolutely you
can do all kinds of stuff
actually we have a framework that is
coming is it in this version
that is the uh what
this user adding import export stuff is
that sean you would probably know that
right um there's already the tutorials
developing an import converter and
developing an export converter
we are working on all of the internal
utilities that would be needed to
really make this robust enough to bump
into system i'm
nearing the end of a long series of
framework projects that are i'm heading
in that direction
okay fair enough all right i think we i
think we have a solution here
um and uh i think i need to go
so thanks everybody i will push these
changes
and um uh
thanks guys see you later thanks to
folks on the live stream and i think we
have another live stream
coming up we have two more today
oh my gosh we have at 3 30 eastern time
we have my weekly science and technology
q a for kids and others and
right after that we have a design review
about
geography and dates so
all sorts of interesting things but
before that i have two other meetings
about utterly different topics
um all right